our London town a modern metropolis
built on history and prosperity only
took 12,000 years to build it up and one
night to tear it all down oh my god
listen ami get all your units to move in
and lock down the sick
with London under attack by a mysterious
terrorist the government turns to a
private military company called Albion
to keep everyone safe what could
possibly go wrong
ladies and gentlemen mr. Nigel Cass CEO
of Albion he's kindly stepped up to
establish order understand this I will
not allow anyone not even myself to
jeopardize this he will stop at nothing
to permanently control the city
London will be the first city in the
world to be made truly safe
Nigel's not the only opportunist who's
taken a liking to this fair city
meet Mary Kelly head of the most
powerful crime syndicate in London
eschew and spread the word
she and her goons are using the dark web
to sell everything from party pills to
people is scary I know but I've got to
keep tracks on my merchandise the guy
you make me a slave you do not want to
ruffle her feathers
with the city out on its ass it now
falls on you to build a resistance and
take back London any of the brave London
as you see walking the streets can be
recruited into your team like him
everyone could become your next secret
weapon in our first mission we need to
get some dirt on Nigel Cass and that
means breaking into Albion headquarters
inside the Tower of London all the hardy
souls you see here are people we have
recruited from the streets of London
they all have unique abilities and
you're free to tackle this mission with
whoever you like dick got my eyes magley
get to work and let's never talk about
this again
like everyone in dedsec Arthur can hack
pretty much whatever but as a
construction worker he has a particular
set of tools that make him handy
he could even call his own cargo drone
perfect for gate-crashing when you're
not invited and who needs a regular old
gun when you have a bloody nail gun
Omega soy dude [ __ ] bored
boys nothing
perhaps we could approach this mission
differently if you'd rather keep your
distance we've got you covered
Amy is a drone expert what have we here
a real tech connoisseur hate spiders but
love this one what an adorable creepy
crawler a drone expert does have the
unique ability to summon their own drugs
this little darling is fast and stealthy
I'm reading incoming drones
she could also hack enemy drones turning
the tide in her favor
and if you are not into direct
confrontation there are more ways than
one to get the job done recruiting an
Albion officer like Brielle here might
be challenging but it'll get you inside
restricted Albion areas don't mind me
just doing VidCon for a bunch of
insurgents however do anything
suspicious and she'll probably wind up
with a bullet in the back of her head
we're missing the human element here I
can get the defense minister on the line
right now look if you feel you must
[Music]
premon ORS running our streets illegals
threatening our families but police
commissioner himself
assassinated by terrorists well that
seems to be enough evidence next up
we're crashing Mary Kelly's organ
farming operation and putting a stop to
it and we need a hard nut for this
impairing our frontal lobe again are we
bugs don't disturb me in my natural
habitat say hello to Mickey the man
lives for his team that put another
arrow on the chest and doesn't mind
getting his hands dirty
he does have a slight drinking problem
though oh well we'll come back to him
you know what let's go with someone a
bit more professional
it's almost crass to call him a hitman
[Music]
some might even call him an artist
[Music]
[Music]
here's the bastard responsible done and
dusted bad not bad if I do say so le not
everyone in London is a legendary
assassin or a super spy but everyone can
be a hero
[Music]
so get out there find the best recruiter
and build your resistance
to take back London
[Music]